the gyro can experience what's gonna be
real weird to see what happens when they
turn it back on again
Ryan Society goes back how long is it
gonna take for us to even out cuz it's
gonna be a rocky restart it's gonna be
Rocky
yeah there's gonna be some warm-up you
know it's gonna yeah I saw an article
that we're saying people are criticizing
governor Newsom for opening up too soon
I'm like stay home stay home don't tell
everybody to stay home you stay home
right you stay home enough we can't just
stay home forever this is not a valid
strategy for dealing with the virus this
is not how it works there's all this
talk hmm
all this talk like as if anyone has the
correct answer it is savvy I mean you
know we were talking about it earlier
that you know all these businesses are
gonna go under like the you know you
know childcare and barbershops and stuff
like that it's like gems and they didn't
do anything wrong they didn't they did
everything right and you know yeah no
maybe in hindsight it's gonna turn out
that it was the right thing to do and
then it stopped the spread of the virus
and even though there was some flare-ups
here and there that made people more
aware and the virus eventually goes away
maybe it's possible but even if it's not
the right thing to do I think people are
just you know doing it out of caution
because we don't know what it is
but it's not the only strategy there was
other strategies that could be employed
and they could have made people more
cognizant and protecting themselves it
would have really greatly slowed the
risk of transmission and I think you
could have let people stay working let
me tell people they can't work I don't I
don't like that you know I don't like
that not just because it's
unconstitutional I don't like that
because I don't like people telling
people what to do and I don't like that
because I don't like one person being in
charge of figuring out what's right or
wrong I don't know it's one person or a
hundred people but what's right or wrong
for an entire state of 40 million people
together and to make up the mind for
them based on what based on just because
you have voted in the office right that
doesn't make any sense to me you should
be dealing with like legitimate problems
not controlling the population through
some Orwellian mandate we just deem it
that everyone has to stay home then you
even
offer rewards for people in LA the mayor
was offering rewards for people turning
people in who weren't social distance
saying yeah that just that opens up a
kind of warmth it's like it's not all
the wrong moves that's not gonna help
anyone you know when I heard that though
the whole thing that you can basically
snitch on somebody not wearing a mask or
not do we get money yeah yeah your your
sudden people up - yeah it's not a good
thing dude so did you ever see the
article where it says normally its
snitches get stitches but in this case
it's snitches get ruined like they're
even calling it a snitch and and it was
an official thing that they release oh
my god some marketing person was like
yeah I got the thing I don't know if it
was an official thing or was the article
on it it was in the LA Times whatever it
was I was like what are you saying this
is a terrible idea you're encouraging
people to turn people in for rewards do
you not understand psychology like this
people that have grudges against people
there's people that are up they don't
like their neighbor they're just gonna
turn each other in right you can't keep
people that kind of power right give
people the power just say cam it's him
he's got the scarlet letter and then
then [ __ ] they look up your ass with
a microscope see if you've been social
distancing hey Suze I got my eye on you
six feet six feet ask hand sanitizer
yeah stay safe stay home watch your head
I'm going into a cop car I don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing man they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
no one knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
for them to tell us what to do look
definitely you have to do know maybe you
should do it that way maybe you should
wear a mask and you just stay home don't
don't tell me what to do they already
have had this on the county page for
like snitches get rewards for turning
people in for crimes
well now crimes I still don't like the
reward the reward should be you're a
good citizen like if you see someone
breaking into someone's car you manage
to catch their plate you should turn
that in because you're a good citizen
you should cash you get cash receive
payment for the yeah I don't know man
yeah I think a lot of silly stuff you
give people money for things you
incentivize them you know it makes it
dangerous because you can't there's an
Senta to go one way or the other so if
someone sees a crime and they want to
turn that you know they want to give up
the information about that crime whether
it's a license plate or description or
you got a video or some one time you do
that because you're a good person you
don't want your mom to get robbed like
that you do that because you don't want
your neighbor to get robbed you could do
that because there's a problem in your
community there's a person who's
committing a crime and as a community we
organize we look we look out for each
other
we found this good this person's [ __ ]
up well like the inception of this
program wasn't it like a like a
neighborhood watch program like you
always see that you always see these
signs it's like who is in his
neighborhood watch program yeah that's
the other thing right how much are they
watching you know people are so lazy
this is kind of what there's a bunch of
actual rewards up here right now they're
looking for information on a bunch of
shootings and so I'm sure $25,000
rewards bro here's the thing they don't
have the time they don't have the time
there's so many things that are going on
in LA at all times
somebody breaks in your house like did
you die well we got we got [ __ ] to do
they're not gonna have a full-time
Columbo on the job with the [ __ ]
dusting for fingerprints that kind of
bandwidth or have that kind of
[Applause]